let's give it up for the one
the only alex hermosie
so i feel like a um stand-up comedian
hi
could i have you turn around for a
second
all right
the thing you got at the door at the
front door
now is the time
this thing
just hang out
trust me it won't hurt it'll only hurt
for the first five minutes
do you get one
would you guys not get get these
oh [ __ ]
never mind i thought every hand over
your face everybody
never mind
sorry
we gave everybody
one of these
well for those of you who did decide to
grow a mustache momentarily i do
appreciate it um
i'll tell you that
it looks good
i'll tell you that if you want to have
lots of negative comments on your paid
advertising i highly recommend us a very
distinct piece of facial hair that's
associated with 70s porn stars and
pedophiles i used to get so i still get
the notifications on my phone and uh
layla like i think only like a few weeks
ago she's like you can't keep reading
these i was like you know i feel like
it's toughening me i feel like it's i'm
building character
so anyways uh first off i just want to
say i'm extremely humbled to be here uh
honestly just hearing the few
conversations that i was able to have
with the people who were here
honestly didn't think anyone really knew
who we were
that's not necessarily a bad thing
we keep very much to ourselves i
probably don't leave the house for like
four or five days at a time
so it's a little bit different than i
think maybe most people's
entrepreneurial journey
but nolan am i good to rock
can't see him i'm good to rock okay cool
so uh
kind of what david was saying i like to
understand who i'm talking to so i can
try and cater this a little bit more to
your desires is that cool
okay
so first thing well without it
pretend this is anonymous and no one
else knows you're here
who here is still working a full-time
job can you raise your hand
and for like the one moment of the night
this i'd ask you to just not do the like
hey i'm gonna be too cool to raise my
hand because then it like it's to your
detriment so the second thing who here
is a full-time entrepreneur who's doing
a hundred thousand dollars or less per
year
okay cool
who's doing between a hundred and a
million a year
okay
um who's doing a million plus
okay cool a nice smathering fantastic
all right so um one of the concepts or
one of the things that i get asked a lot
when i go well on the rare occasions
that i go out in public
is
you know how do i make more money how
did you get started what should i be
investing in
and i think that it's really important
to
understand that if someone's able to
achieve something faster than you
they're using the same resources that
you have from a time standpoint and so
it just means that they're allocating
their attention in places that they're
getting disproportionate returns on it
right
and so
the objective is how can we find the
biggest roi
buckets that we put our time into so
that we can extract as much value as
humanly possible as fast as possible
and so
my belief in this is that
information is the single best
investment that you can have because
information is the only thing that buys
you time
does that make sense
a lot of people want to go faster but
then they don't want to spend money on
learning how to go faster and that is
the only thing that gets you from point
a to point b in a shorter period of time
and so
where it gets really interesting is how
do you acquire those skills
and so
i'll give you can i give you two like
habits that i think have done really
well for me in terms of acquiring skills
so
the first thing is like i was up today
at three o'clock in the morning um i'm
usually in bed right now
so
this is my amped voice but i i say that
because i also know some i have a few
billionaire friends who are
who are night owls and so i don't think
it's a morning thing specifically i
think it's more important that you can
always have four to five hours a day of
uninterrupted time to yourself
the biggest breakthrough that i was able
to have in my own life from a business
standpoint came when i was able to move
the big pieces forward every single day
because i started my day that way and
for me that's what i'm the most creative
is in the morning and so that's where i
invest all of my time in getting and
acquiring skills
just so i have an idea is anyone like an
early bird here early birds okay
uh what is early before six
before five
before four
okay
well um it's really big in our community
because like so does anyone know what
gym launch does
okay
a couple people all right can i give you
a 60 second pitch on what we do okay so
we own a company called jim launch we
help small business owners that are
specifically gym owners so crossfit's
boot camp semi-private facilities uh mma
bjj type facilities that are service
based facilities um on average increase
their top line revenue by 240 000 a year
they uh decrease their turn from ten
point four percent to six point eight
percent month over month which is
awesome they triple their profit on
average
and that's in their first 11 months
working with us uh every nine days we
create another million dollar facility
so we're pretty good at it that has been
the focus of pretty much my entire adult
life it started when i had my chain of
gyms in teller california i was able to
open up a new facility every six months
as a 23 year old off of cash flow so i
pre-sold every facility so that i could
open them at full capacity on the first
day
i thought everyone was doing that i
didn't know that that was something that
was different
and so i had my six i sold them when i
was 26
and then i started flying out with my
lovely wife
who is my girlfriend that i met on
bumble at the time uh that i got to uh
quit her job
and join me her parents were very stoked
that she left her
job for some bumble dude on the internet
to go launch gyms
and so
she uh so we would actually fly out to
these gyms and do basically like bar
rescue we do gym rescue and uh i did
that for six months and then we had an
eight-man team and then we did that for
another six months so every
month we'd go out to eight gyms and
launch them and we'd go from zero to
full capacity in 21 days and we did that
over and over and over and over again
that short period of time that i was
referencing in the beginning when i was
when i had my own six facilities
during that period of time
i looked back at our crm
and i had done over 4 000 101 sales
in that three year period and so i had
my and that was actually closes because
i couldn't count consultations you said
no so i did a lot of sales and
i'm telling you this because a lot of
people ask like how did you get here
without knowing how
how to replicate what happened and so
despite the fact that gym launch
in march of 2017 is when we transition
to the model that we have now which is
an information based model we consult
and we help them implement the systems
to acquire customers uh send them
increase the value of their services and
then keep them longer
but
it's understanding the things that got
you there because for us we were able to
go from zero to a 50 million dollar a
year run rate within 20 months
and so a lot of people think that
that comes from nothing
but a lot of it's the eating [ __ ] period
hopefully the profanity is okay
and so
when i had my conversation with david
and some like my sales guys come up to
me and they're like dude i got 25 grand
you know i'm feeling pretty good so i'm
just like curious you know what kind of
investments should i be getting into you
know like crypto's looking pretty good
right now
and um and it drives me nuts
because i'm pretty sure i didn't have
any money in my bank account at any time
until
i had a million dollars in my bank
account within a couple months
and
the reason for that was because my
belief is that you should spend all of
the money that you have to acquire
skills
until you can't spend money on acquiring
skills anymore and you can pretty much
always spend money on to acquire skills
it's you just do it differently and so
like the higher up you go now i have to
make donations to charities in hundreds
and millions of dollars in order to get
access to the boards of these charities
who are other dudes who can donate
hundreds of thousands and millions of
dollars to those charities so that i can
then see what they know so that i can
learn faster
and so
i'm going to give you an example of what
this whole concept of
talent stacking is
so
let's say you're good at math right so
that's where you're starting you're like
i'm good at math cool that's a skill not
very monetizable but it's a skill
and then you're like okay well
i could kind of do credits and debits
keep someone's books
great that's a level one skill you've
now put two skills together and now you
have something that is actually
monetizable and then you're like you
know what i'm gonna learn accounting all
right so i'm gonna get my degree in
accounting so i'm gonna become a cpa all
right now this is something that is
becoming more valuable
and then you learn about tax strategies
right and then all of a sudden you're
able to work with a business and save
them hundreds of thousands or millions
of dollars a year because of your
understanding of the tax code and then
you learn how to decrease liability with
insurance
because you continue down this path of
stacking your skills
and then if i'm if you're if you're
following along and like the next round
would be like and then i understood how
to talk to
bankers and financiers and raise funding
and do
do exits and equity deals etc
same person
stacks one talent on top of the other
and each talent becomes
disproportionately more valuable than
the talents all before them
does that make sense
and so it's it's a it's a it's a hockey
stick right and so in the beginning you
don't make anything for a very long time
and so if you're in the crowd right now
and you have not been able to increase
your income for an extended period of
time which i would define as probably a
year
if your income has not had a significant
increase in that period of time it's
because you've chosen to not look or
understand what the next skill that you
need to stack on top of your prior skill
is
in the entrepreneur world
usually who would consider themselves
pretty decent at sales
most entrepreneurs right we're more
promoter type people
and so
i hear this stuff all the time
there's no good sales people i can't get
anyone to sell like i can sell
what's the skill that that person lacks
they lack the ability to hire
find recruit
train and manage a salesperson
that's lots of skills but that's the
essence of what they're missing
then they have one or two sales people
or three salespeople and they're like
man we have good months and then we have
bad months and then we have good months
i can't keep it solid like why isn't it
it's always variable right what's the
skill they lack
they don't know how to manage a sales
team
and so
the biggest piece of advice that i can
say is that it's a frame shift
that everything is 100 your fault
and at the same time there are self-made
millionaires and self-made billionaires
but there are also self-made 50 000 a
dollar a year ers they just don't claim
it because they don't want to be
responsible
right and so you're 100 responsible for
the income level that you have and if
you're dissatisfied with it it's because
you're just not that valuable
and so you have to learn how to become
more valuable and the first way to do
that is to admit that you have a deficit
and so if you have an ego about it
you'll be incapable of becoming better
than you are
does that make sense
the people who you see who are really
talented and then cap is because they
can't admit that they're not good
or they could be better
i want to give you a different example
for the talent stacking because i want
to show that like the math one's pretty
simple because everyone understands it
so let's say
jay-z
when he started his career he understood
he had a rhythm right he was naturally
pretty good with beats okay got it
then all of a sudden he learned how to
perform another skill so he he took his
sensitivity to music etc and then he
learned how to perform okay great
once he learned how to perform then he
learned how to sell and market his own
materials
another big skill
then after that he learned how to create
a label
a more leveraged skill then he learned
how to attract and find other skilled
performers and bring them into his label
and promote them
all he did was stack one talent on top
of the other and for every additional
talent he had he got exponential returns
on the stack that was underneath of it
does everyone here understand what the
next skill that you lack is
is there any reason why you're not
aggressively pursuing it if you claim to
not have what you want
if you don't wake up at 3 o'clock or 4
o'clock in the morning and you're
dissatisfied
i don't get you
because for me dissatisfaction is so
soul-crushing that like i will do
anything to not feel that way and so it
might not be in the morning it might be
after you put your kids to bed but like
there has to be that time where you can
invest in learning those skills so that
you can stack the next thing
so one of the issues with being newer in
the entrepreneur space is that
you see a course that's marketed you're
like copywriting right if i buy this
copywriting course it says i'm going to
make money right if i buy this traffic
course it says that i'm going to make
money if i buy this funnel course money
sales course money right the reality is
that it's all yes's and all knows for me
it's just the weekly i choose to
dedicate my bank to your first dollar
going
absolutely wonderful day where you can
create all the meaning you want i need
to learn how to write copies
advertisements on media platforms i need
to be able to analyze the data to know
how it's actually doing and know how to
adjust it based on the performance i
need to know how to create landing pages
that convert traffic once i have a lead
holy [ __ ] i have a lead
once i have a lead i have to know how to
get that person nurtured in such a way
that they will
eventually convert and whether that's a
phone sale or that's going towards a
nurture sequence those are two different
paths those are different conversion
mechanisms but the points is you see how
each of these is a skill that you have
to acquire
right and so whenever you see these
courses don't get
butthurt
that you didn't make a million dollars
after buying one course
you're not supposed to
and so
the goal is to get as many of them as
you possibly can
the key is having the discernment to
know which is the one that you're
missing right now
right
and so
like the only thing that i'm not sure
how to teach is discernment because it's
the only thing that allows you to
prioritize
and so if you see people who are like i
said earlier are moving faster than
other people it just means that given
the resource that they have that we all
have are equal which is time
they're able to with discernment
allocate that to the highest skill that
would be next in this in the stack of
skills that they need to learn
so
my opinion
is that if you have twenty five thousand
dollars if you have fifty thousand
dollars if you have a quarter million
dollars if you have five hundred
thousand dollars in your bank account i
genuinely believe
that there is no point to trying to save
money
if your income is less than two three
five hundred thousand dollars a year i
don't think there's a point and i mean
that genuinely and that's not a
diminutive way it's just that saving not
going to starbucks
to become a millionaire
congrats you made 40 years and you
enjoyed nothing in life like now you
have a million dollars i feel like
that's not the i mean is that a life
that anyone wanted
right [ __ ] that so
thank you i'll be here all night um
until 9 15. um when i go to bed i'm
kidding um
sorry entreprened totally where was i
yeah yeah so so exactly so
my objective for when you should
actually consider
looking at investments is when you have
so much money coming in
that even when you're aggressively
searching to find a way to allocate the
money to acquire the next skill there's
still an excess and abundance that is
coming on top of it
that is the state that you need to get
to when in my opinion you have like the
alex stamp of approval not that i'm some
whatever but i'm just saying like that
in my opinion is where
it actually starts to make sense
the next piece of it is that once you
have that abundant flow of money that's
coming towards you
you also probably have a lot of skills
and so then looking at investment
vehicles of like
bitcoin the stock market real estate you
have to also understand because all the
things that got you to where you are
like i'm petrified of going into real
estate
because i know that there's guys like me
willing to crush me the moment i go in
there because they know the game and i
don't know the rules yet
and so there's a person in every one of
your spaces who has a talent stack that
far surpasses you and what you need to
figure out is deconstruct look at their
path
so you can figure out what talents they
were able to stack together so that they
can so they're able to continue to crush
you so that eventually you can get
strong enough to crush them right
and so
it takes so long to get good at the game
and the amount of effort
oh this is really okay
i'm trying i wish
okay first off i did not know that we
could have presentation powerpoints i'm
a big visuals person so i apologize
but
the amount of effort the amount of
return that you get from learning a new
skill
goes down with time right your first 20
hours of reading about sales your first
20 hours of sales in general your first
20 sales consults you will learn more
from zero to then than you ever will in
the rest of the career of sales but
despite the fact that you have marginal
returns
the absolute incremental return at the
end
goes up
so an example of that would be an
olympic runner
in the beginning you get much faster
much faster right
and then as they get better and more
advanced and more advanced they're
trying to shave off quarter you know
quarter seconds from their time
and so they put months and years to save
a half a second on their 100 meter right
right here right at the very end but
what's the difference between first
and second
and third
so the absolute return you get on the
very small incremental return you get at
the very end is where all the juice is
when you're just this much better than
everyone else at marketing when you're
just this much better than everyone else
that sales when you're just this much
better at messaging and strategy
then that's when you go like this
and so that's why they have these
overnight successes and it's usually
because they stacked 20 skills and it
was on the 21st skill that the bridge
was finally completed and then it popped
up
has anyone heard the story of the bamboo
tree
okay one person fantastic so you all be
punished for not responding so
so i'm i'm pretty sure this is a chinese
proverb hopefully i'm not butchering it
but essentially a bamboo so if you if
you plant a bamboo tree
and you keep it underground
and you look and you wait a whole season
and it doesn't seem like it's growing
the stubborn farmer will go and dig it
up and try and plant it again be like i
must have been a bad seed right and the
stubborn farmer goes back a year later
ah must have been a bad seed changes the
area changes the sunlight changes the
watering changes all of these things
constantly right but the wise farmer
knows that he plants it and it takes
five years for the
the sapling to break the ground
and then within the first three months
it's like 60 feet tall
because it's spending the whole time
digging down rather than digging up so
that it can have the root system to
support the growth and talent stacking
works the exact same way
so
i want to make sure that i
is there a direction that you'd want me
to take this at all or is that good or
is there a is there like hey i'd like to
know more about selling [ __ ]
or like hey
yes
perfect yep love it
love it yup i will
so he asked an awesome question thank
you he said could you give revenue
guidelines for what skills you need to
acquire at different revenue levels
that's a great question i wish i had a
graph and i could have pondered it more
but
if you're under 100 000 a year in your
business i'm assuming you're
self-employed you probably don't have
anyone else who's working for you it's
probably just you
at that point everything is going to be
about promotion right you're going to
have to know how to market know how to
sell
i highly highly highly highly recommend
never outsourcing anything for as long
as you possibly can so that you can like
i still think i'm probably the best
marketer in my business even though i
have a whole department and i know how
to make adjustments on what they're
doing and i also know who's trying to
[ __ ] me right i know what ad costs
are supposed to be and the only way that
you know that is having done it
the same thing with sales don't try and
hire a sales guy because you're like
well i'm not good at sales well then
that's always going to be a weak link
for you
and you're never going to have a good
sales team because you don't have the
the confidence to be able to look back
at them in the eye and say like this is
wrong you're not doing it right they're
going to be like well how do you know
and you're not going to be able to have
the confidence to look back and have an
answer
and so in the beginning it's all about
okay
i'm going to pause that
does anyone want to have like the 100
million dollar blueprint
okay great
so if you want to get to a 100 million
dollar valuation type company
in my opinion the way that you have to
do it
is get really [ __ ] good at one thing
and this is what david was talking about
earlier so i wanted to make sure i
brought it up
and i mean so good
that people start coming to you because
of how good you are because how people
talk about you
if you don't have that happen that is
the quota for not being good enough
it means you need to keep doing that
thing until you have past the
incremental return where it starts going
like this
and in some businesses that means
referrals and that's usually what it
starts with
until you're so good at that thing you
do nothing else
and it's counter to your entrepreneurial
character to stay disciplined enough on
this one track because you want to be
scatterbrained and chase the next
opportunity and dig up your seed and
start another one and dig up your seed
and start another one i'm going to do
fitness for a while actually i want to
be a marketing agency actually i want to
sell a course
actually i want to do a webinar you know
affiliate marketing sounds cool
sound familiar anyone right
if you get so [ __ ] good at any of
those things any one of them you can get
to 100 million
i had a friend who called me and i'm
going to complete that i had a friend
who called me
from high school
and he's got a roofing company he was
like yeah you know we we buy these homes
and then we we we fix them and we flip
them and i was like that's awesome man
he's like uh we also do windows i was
like okay he's like we also do roofs
though and that's like really our bread
and butter and i was like okay
he's like so like you know so this is
what i'm thinking we got and i was like
great so pick one he's like what do you
mean i was like pick one
like any one of them can be a 100
million dollar business the biggest
fallacy that you have as an entrepreneur
is that you need more things
to make more money
when it's the opposite you need less
things to make more money and it's the
only way you'll make more money is when
you do less so that you can get better
and dig deeper
because that's how you're going to be
better than everyone else because the
other guys you're competing against are
also scatterbrained as [ __ ] right and so
you can out discipline them by knowing
that you're going to dig deep and deep
and deep and deep i can say with a lot
of confidence that there aren't too many
people who know how to make a gym as
profitable as me it's been really boring
for me for a very long time
i really understand how to make gyms
profitable but we stay here and we still
keep innovating and figuring out new
things because we try and put blinders
on so that i don't look at the other
opportunities so that we can keep
getting better and better and better
once you have your one skill so i'm
coming back
once you have your one skill
you can then monetize teaching that
skill
now you have a high margin business that
has high value because you really are
good at that thing now remember it takes
years to become good enough that people
talk about how good you are before you
enter the room
and when you leave people like dude that
guy's [ __ ] legit
that's what you want if you don't have
that you're not good enough in my
opinion everyone wants to start
preemptively but their product isn't
strong enough and then they fizzle
because they they can't hit the next
level because their actual product isn't
strong enough
so
thanks man appreciate it i thought it
was the music i was like ah [ __ ] okay
um
so
you have your first skill so you've got
your years right we're talking about
what revenue levels if you're doing your
revenue level it's awesome that you're
like that you're making money but you
have to just keep doing that thing until
you get so good at it that you're stock
full like you can't take any more
clients and then you raise your prices
and then you do it again and then you
raise your prices and then you do it
again and then you raise your prices
then you do it again and you keep doing
that and so you're the most sought after
at that point you can then sell that
skill that you have acquired whether
you're a videographer whether you're a
graphic designer whether you're a
salesperson whether you're a marketer
any of those skills are skills that
other people value and you can teach
people how to do it in a very high
margin environment now when you have
your high margin environment business it
is not a business that has enterprise
value
because it's you you've just productized
your skill does that make sense
which means that after you've taken out
the profits from that business and that
which should 100 percent be your
objective in that first phase first is
skill acquisition second is monetization
of that skill
third is reinvesting the profits from
that high margin business into a
business that does have enterprise value
that does not require you
so that could be software that could be
product that could be
anything
once you have that
you use the talent stack that you've
acquired up to this point to grow that
business to the point that you can then
flip it and sell it
does that make sense
that's the 100 million plan or billion
depends how big you play but that's
exactly how you do it if you have no
money which is how i did it well hold on
not that i did it what i'm saying is
like that's
who here has funding like from my
outside vendor
okay
three people so for everybody else who's
bootstrapping that was for you
if you have outside money you can start
in different ways and i think that
there's some disadvantages to that as
well because then there's some talent
stacks that you skip over that then you
don't know
you got this jet pack and then you don't
know what the missing link is when you
get there
so
if you hit a plateau who here has been
at a plateau for over a year
okay awesome great this is for you
right now you're not good enough
you're not good enough
and if you can accept that and
internalize it then you can create
actions around the thing that you need
to do and do over and over and over
again the actions that you need to take
has to be in terms of number of volume
and so what i mean by that is if you're
like i'm just not that good at sales
cool
how many consultations can you get into
per day
i'm not that good at marketing one of
the best things i was ever given was
from ezra firestone if you've ever heard
of him um
he was at a small event a private event
with me and some other guys and he said
i take a percentage a fixed percentage
every month of my marketing spend and i
spend it on crazy ideas that i have with
zero intention of making an roi
and he did that because there was no
point in him trying to learn from other
marketers at that point because he was
above most of the marketers courses that
were out there
and so the only way that he could learn
was by learning in the real world
and so each of the skills that you're
lacking has a way to do that it can be
taking more sales it can be saying i'm
going to always create so where's my
videographer where's nolan somewhere
if i'm nolan i'm going to think every
single day i'm going to make two
commercials
every day i'm going to make two
commercials and every day we're gonna
run them and i'm gonna see which ones
did better and i'm gonna do i'm gonna
deconstruct the ones that did well
and then i'm gonna try and do more of
those until i get so [ __ ] good at it
that every single video that i make is a
winner
and i'm gonna keep doing that and it
doesn't take a week or a month it
usually takes years right that's how it
works i was on a podcast not that long
ago and um
the host has a slightly younger male
audience and he was like you know man i
know you always talk about doing the
boring work and just like eating [ __ ]
and like waking up at you know midnight
um he's like and you know you totally
suffered and we love that that's great
but um so for anybody who like wants
that success and wants to just shortcut
that like what's your advice to them
um and uh
i was like you're not going to
like you're you're not going to because
you're not going to be good enough
because the guy who did do that and took
4 000 101 sales
is gonna be better
and
one question that layla and i got at
this event a while back was a lady in
the audience said
how are you guys so certain like when
you guys talk about your gyms or when
you talk about your business how are you
so certain
um
and i think that level of certainty just
comes from being like i did it four
thousand [ __ ] times like it's not
like it's not like i wake up i say my
affirmations like i'm a i'm a gym guru
i'm a gym guru i'm amazing i'm an expert
you know what i mean i'm an expert like
i just it kills me
um
because
it gets to a point where you've done it
so many times that it's not amazing it's
not fantastic you're just stating
observations of history
and when you get to that point that's
when you've probably acquired the level
of mastery
that is required to be able to monetize
that skill
does that make sense
okay cool
so
i think i went probably way over so
anyways uh thank you guys i'm very
honored to be here i appreciate you
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]